[Musique]
oui c'était quel sujet bassett armure
cette armure de merde pour commencer bon
déjà on est en blanc c'est hyper grillé
à 8,1 topoi granby très mauvais match
c'est pas fini c'était quand même chier
d'apporter tout cet attirail et au
premier couplet faiseur on est mort
autre chose oui ce casque mes yeux mes
yeux là ils sont à ce niveau là et la
visière elle et 10 cm au dessus donc on
arrive à tirer sur personne
bon on va dire quelque chose on va
essayer d'améliorer les casques oui ce
serait au sujet de la seule meuf que
j'ai croisé de ma vie la princesse leia
oui elle est bonne
oui et en plus d'être bonne elle est
drôle charismatique intelligente
indépendante elle est parfaite c'est pas
une plainte ça si elle est parfaite et
c'est ma soeur [ __ ] la seule map que
je pouvais me taper dans toute la
galaxie
ces masters
je me suis fait vous êtes le chasseur de
primes le plus classe de la galaxie
justement où ça vous pose un problème
d'être super stylé super bad ass je suis
super g la mort la plus ridicule de
l'histoire tués et le cri que je prouve
ce coiffeur ridicule et on fait comme si
j'étais pas vraiment tort si vous voulez
j'ai reçu des propos de bon c'est pas
été validés donc dans des zones sérieux
j'ai dit dès au seigneur vador somme
octobre john l'a pas vous voilà dans les
chaumières mais c'est un vrai problème
pour viser un mois j'ai un collègue par
exemple il a réussi une fois touché une
rebelle à l'épaule bas après s'est fait
tirer dessus il est tombé direct parce
que les armures sont en plastique elle
regarder c'est de la merde
bonjour je connais mes parents otez moi
d'un doute vous n'allez pas me faire le
coup de en fait mon père c'est un luxe
qui cette personne extrêmement sexy a
laissé une belle plante ccn ma soeur ok
civitas et quoi passer aux quatre
couleurs les codes couleurs primaires
prête pierre vraiment la classe sont oui
mais vous êtes bien le sida comme ça je
sais pas si je peux en cacher une autre
histoire
et tout le monde se fout de ma gueule sa
vie / l'établé bon écoutez j'ai demandé
à ce qu'on revoie la copie pour les
armures et les casques donc maintenant
s'il vous plaît un peu de patience c'est
une belle courbe au niveau de la fesse
ya rien à retoucher seulement
laissez moi deviner mais si vous allez
vous plaindre que vous comprends pas
c'est lui et ses parents le stylo donc
voilà qui fait un peu même est ce que
vous avez ressenti combien d'embrasser
sur la compare d'inceste l important est
ce qu on pourrait parler de mon père
[Musique]
je mettais ma mère alors voilà nickel
bas les yeux sont toujours là quoi genre
d'en face que c'est chiant mais hier
mieux malgré tout ouais non esthétique
non il ya un mieux c'est vrai clairement
mais bon là où vous disposez
il ya du changement au niveau du
boulevard du pas la même chose c'est pas
aussi galbées faut que tu as changé
quelque chose au niveau du dumoulin
ouais bah c'est pas bon à [ __ ] ça ça
me saoule c'est qu'on me saoule toute la
journée
l'acteur qui me comprend bah oui
luc abonne toi la chaîne de golden
moustache
je vais essayer fait le ne le fait pas
il n'y a pas eu d'essais